[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
JON SKEET: So good afternoon.
We hadn't met before
this afternoon,
but we've had a
very productive hour
and a half getting
to know each other
and talking with other Googlers.
But my guess is that
most of you won't yet
have read Catherine's book.
So I wonder if you
could start off just
by telling us a bit about
the book itself and I guess
what made you write
it in the first place.
CATHERINE MAYER: With pleasure.
And I hate to start
by contradicting you.
But of course, we
haven't met in person.
But we know each other online.
And one of the things
that's been interesting
is we've been having ongoing
discussions about gender
equality and the difficulties
of reaching it online.
And the reason I wrote this
book was because I couldn't--
I went out looking
for a book that
would tell me the things
that are in this book,
and I couldn't find it.
So I wanted to find a
book that would tell me
where the debate was now
that would possibly explain
to me what the different
waves of feminism
were but, much more importantly,
would explain how it was
that here we were in this
century, in this year,
and that there is still
nowhere in the world that's
gender-equal and what
were the mechanisms that
were holding women back.
And I went to look for a
book that had all of that,
and I couldn't find it.
So I started thinking that
maybe I'd better write it.
There's another twist to that
story that I may get to later.
But then there was
another missing element
that I didn't realize until I
was already writing the book.
And this was in May 2016.
The political party
that I founded--
the Women's Equality Party--
ran its first-ever elections
for the London Assembly,
for the Welsh Assembly, and
for the Scottish Parliament.
And when I was out
canvassing on the doorstep,
I discovered that perhaps one
of the reasons that we had not
made faster progress
to gender equality
was because people didn't
know what it looked like
or what it would be like.
There was nowhere in the
world you could point and say,
of course we want to
be in this society,
because what a
lovely place it is.
And in fact, people
had ideas about it
that were all about repression.
They were all about a
place that would enforce
some kind of gender neutrality,
rather than diversity,
and that would censor and ban.
And I thought, no, no, that's
not what we're working for.
And then there were
also questions about,
would a gender-equal world
be more equal in other ways?
Would a gender-equal world just
simply replicate the world that
we have now, but have some women
with big shoulder pads who were
just taking the place
of the men and--
JON SKEET: The
eponymous 50 foot women.
CATHERINE MAYER: Well, possibly.
So again, I felt that needed
to be in some way described.
And I realized I had a really
clear idea of what I thought
a gender-equal world
would be, but maybe I'd
better try and find a
way of telling people.
So in this book, I not
only label the mechanisms
that hold women back,
but I then take you
on a tour of a gender-equal
world that I call Equalia.
Though yesterday, I was
interviewed on the BBC,
and the interviewer told
me that it was Equalia
and that that was
BBC pronunciation.
And who am I to gainsay the BBC?
JON SKEET: Well, it's nice
that they've considered it.
CATHERINE MAYER: Yes.
JON SKEET: So you sort
of dropped in there
"the political party
that I founded."
Now I'm sure most of us have
founded political parties?
Any-- no?
No?
You describe how
you accidentally
founded a political party.
Do you want to
tell us that story?
CATHERINE MAYER: Well,
it's not dissimilar to why
I wrote the book.
I have a habit, if I can't
find something I want,
of creating it instead.
So in 2015, there's a
fantastic festival--
I don't know if any
of you know it--
called the Women of the
World Festival, WOW,
at the Southbank Center.
And I went to that festival.
And there was an event
about women in politics.
And it was involving
three fantastic female MPs
from the three
biggest old parties--
or at the time,
the Conservatives,
Labor, and the Lib Dems.
And I was listening to
women talking in the cafe
before that event,
and they were all
saying that they
were so disillusioned
with the political
parties that they
weren't going to vote at all.
And the idea of women not
voting when we are not even yet
at the 100-year celebration
of the partial enfranchisement
of women was one I found
deeply distressing.
But it also made me think
about how very depressed
I was with mainstream
politics, as somebody
who has, both as a journalist,
covered politics for the best
part of 30 years, but also been
politically active and engaged.
And yet, I didn't feel
any of those parties
were speaking to me.
And I thought that they were all
talking about gender equality
but not delivering it.
And so at this meeting,
when the Q and A opened up,
I got to my feet.
And I said to the politicians
on stage how much more excited
we would all be if one
of them, or all of them,
were the leaders
of their parties.
And the room sort of erupted.
And I said, but you're
not, and maybe we
need to think about ways to
create change within politics.
And I'd been watching UKIP.
And it was really clear to
me that the main parties,
in seeing UKIP
gaining popularity,
instead of challenging
its positions
were trying to make
themselves more like UKIP.
So I said, what about if we
do the same thing for gender
equality?
What if we found a
women's equality party
and we proved that gender
equality is a vote winner?
Will those big parties start
trying to make themselves
more in that image?
And I said, anyway, if
anyone wants to discuss it,
I'll be in the bar,
which got taken
to be an invitation to everyone
to join me at the bar, which
could have been really
expensive And indeed,
given what's happened
to my life since,
was very expensive,
because also then,
by the time I got
home, social media had
decided not that I was
saying might it be an idea--
[PHONE RINGING]
Oh.
--might it be an idea to
found a party, but saying I
was going to found a party.
And then the final bit to
this story is that I rang--
many of you may know
who Sandi Toksvig is.
She's a fantastic journalist,
presenter, comedian, writer.
She can do everything.
She's also a really good cook
and baker, and it's amazing.
But she and I had been on the
founding committee of the WOW
Festival.
And we had been talking
for a while about how
frustrated we were at the
slow progress towards gender
equality.
So I rang her up and said,
this thing's happened
and people think I'm
starting this party.
And instead of saying,
that's interesting,
she said, but that's my idea.
And I said, what are
you talking about?
And she said, at the
end of WOW every year,
she does something called
"Mirth Control," which
is a fantastic finale.
And she was
intending to showcase
a women's party and a sort
of women's government.
And she said, Darling, would you
like to be foreign secretary?
So that sort of set us off
on this very interesting
experiment to see
whether you can start
a party that will do this.
And the answer
appears to be yes,
because we now have 65,000
members and registered
supporters and more than
70 branches across the UK.
JON SKEET: Fantastic.
And I have to say,
I'm a member myself--
[APPLAUSE]
--which is how all of
this today came about.
So you mentioned
there being a lack
of a vision for what a
gender-equal world would be
and also that when
you spoke with people
before the proposition of
the Women's Equality party
that current political parties
weren't doing politics in a way
that's engaged.
Do you get the feeling
there was a vision for what
more engaging politics
would look like at all?
And does that-- slightly
leading question as well.
You mentioned that you were
taking some ideas for UKIP.
But I know personally
that I don't
think the Women's Equality party
really works in the same way
as UKIP, other than the
idea of taking votes.
CATHERINE MAYER:
Well, there is, I
hope, another parallel with
UKIP, which is, whatever you
think of them, they have proved
that a party with extremely
small amounts of
elected representation
can create seismic
political change.
Now I observed that before
the Brexit referendum.
But at their peak, they have
never had more than two MPs.
And yet, they have changed the
course of this country totally.
So I'm saying, we can
do this in a benign way.
In that sense, we can be like
UKIP, not in any other sense
that I can think of.
But I would say-- well, there is
one other way in which they may
have, at times, been better.
And that is in actually
understanding who their voters
were and talking to their voters
and engaging on grassroots
level, because one of the things
about mainstream politics--
and it's interesting sitting
in Google's headquarters
and talking about this-- but
the digital revolution has had
a very interesting effect on
mainstream politics, which is,
quite a lot of people have
retreated into a sphere where
they don't actually go
out and talk that much--
where they substitute
the digital interaction
for the real interaction.
But that's part of a much
bigger process that's going on.
And I don't actually want to
entirely blame the mainstream
parties for what's
happening, because also,
part of the digital
revolution is
a loss of trust in public
institutions, public bodies--
a kind of rapid cycling of so
many things that are going on.
And it's creating crises.
And it's creating turbulence.
But one of the things, I
guess, that happened with us
is that we saw in
that turbulence
a possibility of
beneficial change,
as well as the dangers
that you see around you.
And so we leapt into the
space that that was creating
that wasn't there before.
And there's something
else I'd say,
which is, the political
system in this country
is a very, very bad one in
terms of letting in newcomers,
in terms of preserving things
that are dead and should
have been cleared away.
So that's another reason
the mainstream parties
have got the way they are.
They're protected
but also damaged
by a system that allows them
to assume that they own votes
rather than having to
go out and earn them
and that allows them
to resist change
and is also incredibly good
at keeping out women in ways
that I try and
explain in the book
and that were, in some
ways, revelatory for me.
Even though I'd covered
politics for 30 years,
I had no idea how
bloody expensive
it was until we
started doing it.
And how that works and
how that keeps out women--
there's a lot I've
learned in these years.
JON SKEET: So I
think we understand
that the Women's
Equality party is not
going to be like other parties.
We've said that we
wish to disband,
which most political parties
aren't ready to disband
as soon as the job's done.
Are there any other
ways where you
think that the Women's
Equality party is really
showing a way forward that
other political parties could
take on?
CATHERINE MAYER:
I would hope so.
Being collaborative,
I think everybody
is really sick of
the politics that you
see that prime
minister's "Question
Time" at Westminster
typifies, which
is that punch-up that you have.
And I was actually
watching it today.
And there wasn't
one moment where
the prime minister or the
leader of the opposition
actually engaged and debated.
What they did was they tried
to score points off each other.
And it is really clear that
one of the reasons people
were being turned off
by politics and not
voting is because for women--
but for a lot of
people in general--
they cannot see themselves
in this kind of shouty,
"you have to be exactly
like this" form of politics.
And they want something more
pragmatic, more collaborative,
something that gets things done.
They understand that it's
very hard to find something
where you're going to agree
with every single opinion
of a party, particularly
one of the ones
that is trying to
legislate for absolutely
everything in the world.
But that shouldn't be
a reason, therefore,
to dismiss the good
things that are happening.
So people want to find ways
of looking at the good things
and moving them forward.
And the old parties
and the old system
entirely mitigates against that.
So practical things we did--
we started by saying,
we are collaborative.
We open our membership to
members of other parties, which
no other party does.
We also said, we are
not left or right.
We are a nonpartisan
political party.
The fight for gender
equality, which
is very often thought to
be a preserve of the left,
is too precious to
be allowed ownership
of a part of the spectrum
that is not doing enough
to move it on.
And anyway, there are vast
areas of common ground
that we can identify
that don't fall
into that left-right spectrum.
And we also invited the other
parties either to work with us
or to steal our policies.
And one of the very
first things we did
is we started going, look,
here's a bright, shiny policy.
Please come and take it.
So I don't think people do that.
And I'm going to point over at
this woman sitting here who--
Halla Gunnarsdottir is our head
of policy and partnerships.
And as you might
guess from the name,
Icelandic and was part of
the Icelandic government
that came in after the 2008
crash and did amazing things.
And we have been learning
from Halla's experience.
But we've also together been
finding ways of doing things
really differently.
So we have got a way of
selecting our steering
committee, for example,
that no other party does.
We do some traditional things.
We vote in some of the members
through our party conference.
We appoint some of the members.
But we also have a complete
random draw of the membership.
And she got to ring up
people and go, hello,
you have been selected to sit
on our steering committee.
And apparently, a couple of
them declined that opportunity.
But everybody else
very eagerly joined.
And it's an interesting way of
making politics more porous,
of bringing people in.
All the candidates
we've run have
been people who have
never stood before
and probably would never
have got through the--
they'd have got through
selection processes
at the end of them,
because they were
incredibly able candidates.
But they would not
have been able to go
through the processes
that you need to go,
in order to reach
those committees, which
involve a lot of time-serving.
And for women-- women so often
have caring duties, one way
or the other.
And for them, it would
have been an impossibility.
And so another thing
that we're doing
is we raised bursaries
for candidates
who can't afford to run.
And we raise money for
childcare costs for candidates.
JON SKEET: I think one
of the wonderful things
we've seen since the
Women's March in January
is in the US, huge numbers
of women, who would never
have thought of
standing for office,
now enrolling with the
various organizations, which
can support them
in a different way.
But I've certainly found
that very, very exciting.
CATHERINE MAYER: I know.
It's one of the
really funny things.
It's like, I don't
want to sound like I'm
grateful to Donald
Trump for anything,
and I really don't
think we should be.
But that election did
something important, which
was, when we first
started the party,
the thing that we
most frequently heard
is, surely a party like
yours isn't necessary.
Surely you already
have gender equality.
You've got the Equal Pay Act.
What more do you want?
And as soon as Donald
Trump was elected,
we had people coming up
to us in the street going,
how fast can you fix things?
So I think the spirit of
the Women's March is--
we are in a period of
new energy and activism.
And actually, we're now
rolling out, we call it,
the fifth wave--
we think there's a fifth wave
of feminism that's starting.
But we're going to be
running activism camps
not just for members of
the Women's Equality party,
but for anybody who
wants to learn what
to do with all their
energy, because that
was the other question.
People coming up is like, this
is terrible, but what do I do?
And so now this is our answer
is like, come and learn
what you can do.
JON SKEET: So one
of the things that I
found sort of selfishly
pleasant in the book
was in one of the
chapters where you
talk about difficult topics--
pornography and prostitution.
And you say you went into
a meeting with strong views
in one way and came out
with lots of questions
and thinking maybe that
wasn't the right way
or even that a
different way was right.
And me, as a novice feminist,
I get confused a lot.
And my guess is that when a
lot of these new activists
come along, there
will be heated debates
about all kinds
of topics where we
may agree that
something is wrong,
but not agree on the
best way forward.
Have you learned
anything you can
share about how that can
be done most productively
and what the dangers are?
CATHERINE MAYER: I guess one
of the most interesting things
for me, in terms of trying
to build a movement that
was as broad and diverse
and inclusive as possible,
was how easily even
ideas about inclusivity
can prove anything but and can
actually start being things
that people argue about.
And it is a constant
frustration, to me,
how splintered the women's
movement can become,
because divide and rule
is a very real thing.
And so what we're
doing is trying
to do exactly the opposite.
And what I was trying
to do with this book is,
there are some areas that
are really difficult.
And when I say I came out of
that meeting with questions,
I'm still finding my way
through some of these things.
And it's because I think
90% of what we need to do
is really straightforward
and really self-evident.
And the shocking thing about
the lack of gender equality
is that everybody knows
that we need to do things.
Everybody knows things like
that diversity in businesses--
the way through from
the top to the bottom--
actually makes those
businesses better.
Everybody knows that
increased female participation
in the economy makes
the economy more vibrant
and, therefore, is good for
everyone, not just for women.
People know those things.
And yet, they still don't
do enough to get to them.
But there are a few issues
that are much more complicated
and where actually
there isn't necessarily
a clean and perfect solution.
And those tend to
be ones where we
can spend way too much energy
fighting when actually, there
are, I think, ways
of talking about it
and ways of coming through it.
And that's one of the things
I've tried to do to the book
is I haven't shied away
from any of the most hotly
contested areas of debate.
But I have admitted the
areas where I don't know
or where it's been
difficult for me,
in an attempt to
try and move things
on from that sort
of thing that says,
this person has one
opinion I don't agree with.
I agree with all of the
rest of these opinions,
but because they hold
that one opinion,
I'm going to put
them out of my life.
And that is something
that happens too often.
And to make this change, we
need as many people as possible
on board for it.
And I hate the phrase "bigger
picture," but in this case,
we really need to see
the bigger picture.
JON SKEET: Right.
You mentioned diversity
and boards and women
in business, in general.
One of the things that
hasn't been resolved for me
is, I think it's
fairly straightforward
to see how if you take a board
that's got 20 men and no women
or 18 men, two women,
adding women to that mix
is clearly going to help
in terms of diversity
of life experience and things.
What's less clear to me is
if you have a board that--
I think there are probably
remarkably few examples
of this-- but if
you had a board that
had 17 women and
three men, is it
that women are naturally
better for boards?
You mentioned in the book being
less risk-taking, for example,
in ways that would
have discouraged
the financial
crisis, for example,
in which case, maybe a 20 women,
no men board is for the best.
Or is it actually
the diversity that's
the most important thing, which
can, of course, be diversity
of all manner of things?
CATHERINE MAYER:
So you know when
you said as a novice
feminist, you sometimes
get yourself in trouble?
You're not in trouble,
I promise you.
But you used the word
"naturally" in there.
And the word "naturally"
is one of the concepts that
is a difficult one, because
we have no idea what
men and women would
be if we were freed
from the constraints of the
socialization of the upbringing
that we have that tells us what
gendered roles are and tries
to impose them, in some cases.
And so one of the things
I also do in the book
is I look at the science.
And I poke at these ideas.
The person who said that if
Lehman Brothers had been Lehman
Sisters, it might
not have collapsed
was Christine Lagarde,
the head of the IMF.
She did say she was
joking when she said that,
but there are a lot of
people who think that women
are more risk-averse.
And there is some research
that suggests that.
But whether women are naturally
more risk-averse or whether--
as in whether this is
a biological thing,
that's a whole other thing.
And actually, research on
this is moving all the time.
But what remains absolutely
stable to your point
is that diversity is
incredibly important,
and diversity meaning
not just people
who look different
or sound different,
but bring different
perspectives and make
each other uncomfortable.
What isn't good is
people in the room
who all feel so
cozy with each other
that they don't
challenge each other.
And then they get into
dangers of group think.
And that's where you see the
great corporate disasters is
you look and go, how on
Earth did this decision ever
get made?
And the answer is
that nobody spoke up,
because they were all used
to being nice to each other
and reinforcing it.
But to give you an example
that's a sort of obvious gender
one, in terms of
then the absence
of female representation at
decision making in politics--
the very famous thing about
treating sanitary items
as a luxury item.
No room that had women in
it, or enough women in it,
would think that
sanitary items could
be classed as a luxury item.
And that's, again, the dangers
of decision making if you only
have men around the table.
JON SKEET: She evokes the
picture of Donald Trump signing
around women's health.
CATHERINE MAYER: Or
indeed yesterday, there
was a picture from Saudi
Arabia of a new girls council,
and it was all men,
the girls council.
JON SKEET: I'm sure I've seen
similar equality commissions
and things in the UK somewhere.
CATHERINE MAYER: Well,
I joked on Twitter
that I'm going to
start a game show.
And it's going to be
called "Cherchez La Femme."
JON SKEET: I think
we should explore
where things can be better.
And this is where we may wish
to bring in Halla, talking
about Iceland.
Rather than me give
the background,
why don't you give
the background
for what Iceland has done
and where they are now?
CATHERINE MAYER:
Well, the thing that's
really interesting about
Iceland is for seven years,
they've been top of the
World Economic Forum's
global rankings of
gender equality.
And it is, in many
ways, a country
that deserves that ranking.
But again, it shows you how
far we still have to go,
if you realize that they still
have a really big gender pay
gap there.
Halla can speak to
these experiences
with more authority.
She can speak to most
things with authority.
One of the jokes
I make in the book
is, Nordic women have missed the
memo that tells them to soften
the edges of their opinions.
But it's one of the
great things about--
the Nordic countries
are all ahead of the UK
on gender equality.
And one of the ways
in which you notice
it is that women find
ways of talking that
are not as apologetic as we
are acculturated to be here.
So I, for years, worked in
various management levels
in journalism.
And I would find myself kind of
trying to let men in the room
think that the opinion
had come from them
rather than me or the
idea to get it through.
And it's something you were
actually semi-trained to do,
which, in the end, is unhelpful.
And it's wonderfully
bracing to be
around women who speak
their minds more directly.
But one of the things that
was most interesting to me--
I felt I had to go and spend
time in Iceland for this book.
And Halla fixed up
for me basically
to meet the whole of
Iceland, because she
knows the whole of Iceland.
And when she hadn't fixed up
for me to meet people, I'd go in
and they'd go, do you
know Halla Gunnarsdottir?
Yeah.
But what I hadn't realized--
I knew that they had had this
famous Women's Day Off in 1975.
And 90% of Icelandic
women took the day
off from paid and unpaid work.
And I'd assumed that that had
been the start of Ireland's--
Iceland's journey to gender
equality, because it had
galvanized the women.
It was only when I got
there that I realized
that it is a nation where
the men are all on board
with the project in a way that
I really wish was true here.
And I'm afraid I was
slightly whinging to John
before I came in that I'm going
round talking about my book
at the moment, or I'd go
around talking about the party,
and we'd get these great crowds.
But there are not enough men.
I'm really pleased
to see the men here.
But the idea that we should be
having these conversations as
if these were women's
issues rather than things
that affect all of us-- men need
to be in these conversations.
And in Iceland, men are
in these conversations.
And so I came back really
excited about the Women's Day
Off.
And I came running into
the office and went,
we have to do it here,
we have to do it here.
So we're working to organize
a Women's Day Off in 2018
where we need 90%--
we just need 90% of women
in this country to stop work
for all or part of the day.
And we're trying to
work out how to do it.
But yeah, when I talk
about the gaps in Iceland,
you see those very clearly.
But I'm right, aren't I,
that Icelandic men are more
with the program than men here.
You've lived here long
enough to feel that.
HALLA GUNNARSDOTTIR: Yeah.
So yes, they are
more [? empowered. ?]
And I think there
are conversations
that I have here that I haven't
had in Iceland for a long time.
So it was almost like
starting over again,
because I got involved
with Icelandic Women's
Movement in the late '90s
and early this century.
And then some of
the conversations
that I'm having here
now are just exactly
the same conversations.
and even from before
that-- so even from
times that I didn't
engage with this conversation,
was too young to do so.
And there are issues
here that I feel
Iceland and most of
the Nordic countries
have solved very long time ago.
And that includes child care
and shared parental leave.
And these are probably
the two policies
that the Women's
Equality party has
that would significantly
change the state of play
here in the UK.
And almost overnight-- a system
of truly serious parental leave
where there is a "use it or
lose it" proportion for men,
for fathers--
it changes everything
overnight, because that
means that they start
taking the time off
to be with their children.
It means that employers
know that dads can
disappear just as well as moms.
And they're even more of a
risk, because they can have kids
until they're like 97.
There's a certain time where
women don't have children
anymore.
And I get a lot of
questions here in the UK,
often from women,
who say, I'm not
planning on having
children, what
does this have to do with me?
And my answer is,
everything, because this
impacts all women and, of
course, all men as well.
Women in a certain
age probably know
that-- that it impacts
the opportunities we have,
the potential salaries that
we may have, and so on.
So it's this understanding
of women's issues
as not only
something-- like what
does this have to do
with me as an individual,
but those are a
collective thing.
And I feel in
Iceland that we are
in a different place for that.
But of course, as you
say, it's no utopia.
And none of the Nordic
countries are a utopia--
far from it.
There's still high rates of
gender-based violence, which
I think is probably the most
significant manifestation
of women's inequality.
But there are some things that
I think can be learned from.
And the Women's Day
Off is one of them.
So I hope all of you join
us in making that happen.
JON SKEET: So I guess to wrap
two previous topics into one,
you've said that you want more
men to show up, basically,
physically to events, but also
in terms of gender equality--
CATHERINE MAYER: Am I allowed
to say I want every man
to read that book as well?
JON SKEET: Yes, absolutely.
CATHERINE MAYER:
Because a lot of men
don't get why it has to
do with them, that point.
And so one of the things
I would really hope--
and this is a rare man.
He's read my book.
Hurrah.
JON SKEET: It is
only out for a week.
So that's fairly rare.
CATHERINE MAYER: So I said I
might get to another story.
So I actually sort of wrote
this book by accident as well,
even though I was explaining I
did it because it didn't exist.
The last book that I
wrote was a bestseller.
And when you have a
bestseller, what happens
is publishers come to you and
say, what's your next book?
And they were all trying to get
me to write a book for them.
And I said, I'd like
to write a biography.
And they were really
pleased, because my last book
had been a biography, and
that was a bestseller.
And then I said,
of Angela Merkel,
and their faces fell
like, she's boring,
we're not interested in her.
And Angela Merkel is most
definitely not boring.
She is one of the most
important political leaders
of my lifetime.
And at the point where
I was proposing it,
it would have been significantly
ahead of this election where,
of course, who knows
whether she's going to be in
later this year or not.
And then eventually, they
were coming back to me
and saying, well, because it's
you, we'll make you an offer.
But they were offering me
really low money for it.
And the money they offer is
based on the expected sales.
And I had bucked the trend,
because I had, as a woman,
under a woman's name,
unlike JK Rowling,
I had written a book
that sold really well
to men, my last book.
And I had, as a woman,
written a biography of a man--
as it happens, Prince Charles.
But that book sold
really well to men
and was by a woman about men.
That doesn't happen
in publishing.
And so the idea of a
woman with a woman's--
not hidden by initials-- not
C. Mayer, but Catherine Mayer
writing a book about a woman,
even though that woman was
the most important
political leader in Europe,
was, for the marketing
departments who did the number
crunching, was bad.
And that's because men do
not buy books by women.
And men are-- again, when
we talk about what's natural
and isn't, everything
in society tells you
that we're not
worth listening to.
And there are all sorts
of famous statistics
about, if I've been
talking a lot--
hopefully because
you want me to--
but if a woman talks a quarter
of the amount of time of a man,
it is perceived by the
man to be already talking
as much as the man.
And in films, there's
all this stuff.
I have the statistics
in the book about films
where in a crowd scene
in a typical film,
it should be 50/50 in
a real world split.
And instead, only 17% of
the crowds will be female.
In cartoons, everybody
tells you "Frozen"
is this wonderful feminist
cartoon by Disneyland.
And it has two princesses
as the main characters.
But they have only
43% of the dialogue.
And the female
characters have 43%
of the dialogue, which is
good, by Disney standards,
because there's one that I
don't know how to pronounce.
I was told I was pronouncing
it wrong the other day.
"Moulan," "Milan"--
JON SKEET: "Mulan."
CATHERINE MAYER: Apparently
the dragon talks more
than the heroine--
the male dragon.
And the heroine speaks less
than anyone else in the film.
So this isn't stuff that's
being done on purpose.
This is all this unconscious
bias playing out.
But it plays out in
really profound ways.
And so when I say, I really
want men to read this book,
or I really want men
to come to meetings,
I really want men to engage with
the issues we're talking about,
because these are issues for
you that directly concern you.
And yet, everything you were
told is that it doesn't-- that
it's women's issues.
We put it in separate silos.
So I kind of have a question
for everyone in the room,
really, which is,
how do you think
we should get men on board?
Sorry, just a small question.
I know I'm supposed
to be answering them.
JON SKEET: If you
raise your hand,
we can bring a mic around.
Yes, that was a real question.
That wasn't hypothetical.
Anyone?
AUDIENCE: I was
just saying, just
change the name of
the theme itself,
because I think
sometimes just the name
itself kind of makes
them feel like they
are going for a specific--
they're supporting
that topic already.
But maybe they just want to
have a general conversation
and just want to know more.
So maybe that will be it.
AUDIENCE: It's half a comment
and a half a question.
I was just really interested.
I'm a marketer as well, so
sorry, on behalf of my people.
My question-- you said that
the marketing department were
fretting because men
don't buy women's books.
Well, maybe they should
be better marketers.
And maybe that's the challenge
we need to lay ourselves down
a bit more is, our
job as a mar-- well,
the way I've always interpreted
my job as a marketer
is to make sure that
the audience access
things that will interest them.
And if I'm a marketer, then
I'm simply not doing my job.
And that's simply
not acceptable.
So the marketers at those
publishers should be thinking,
how can I do this, not, this
product is unmarketable,
in my opinion.
CATHERINE MAYER:
I probably should
defend marketing
departments, only
in the sense that
what they're doing
is, when they have a book pitch,
they look the sales figures.
Has there been another
book on this topic,
and how did it sell?
And there are reasons I explain
in the book for why people
underestimate Angela Merkel.
And she's done it
on purpose as well.
She doesn't actually
like you noticing
how interesting she is.
But the overall
trend of men thinking
that things that are by
women are not for them
is a huge trend.
And I think that
there is definitely
in marketing a tendency to
say, well, this doesn't work,
we already know this doesn't
work, so we won't do it.
So yes, I would hope that
marketing departments would
really start questioning
rather than saying,
this is conventional wisdom,
because conventional wisdom
is usually not wisdom.
JON SKEET: Are these
marketing departments
usually populated
by men or women?
And does it matter?
CATHERINE MAYER: It can be both.
One of the things
you must not assume
is that women are not
inculcated with the same ideas.
And we saw that in
a very graphic way
with the results
of the US election
where although a
majority of black women
voted for Hillary Clinton,
the majority of white women
voted for Donald Trump.
And again, something
I unpick in the book--
but yeah, we are the products
of the same cultural soups.
Sorry if that's a strange
way of putting it,
but you know what I mean.
JON SKEET: So I think--
was there a--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Something you mentioned
right now is that--
the men I've been talking to
when I went to, say, evenings
that had women tech
makers, stuff like that,
where they didn't know they
were actually welcome there
or if when they
came there, women
would look at them like,
you're an intruder,
you're not supposed
to be part of this.
So the invitations themselves--
also something that you said--
that the title can
be intimidating.
And if there were special
sessions for male allies,
that they would
feel more invited.
So I don't really know
how to solve this.
But this has been an issue with
the people I've talked to why
they don't go to these events.
JON SKEET: Thank you.
And just to speak
to that directly
from personal experience, I
joined the Women's Equality
party after reading an
interview in "The Guardian"
where it was made very, very,
very clear that men were
welcome and needed,
because equality is better
for everyone, as
our tagline goes.
So yes, I think that does
definitely have an impact.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
That's so interesting.
And I'm proudly married
to a male feminist.
And we're raising two boys.
And it's been a really
interesting experience,
because even just
things from reading
all the traditional
storybooks, I
hadn't noticed before that I'm
reading to my two-year-old,
indoctrinating this
male-dominated patriarchy,
which I hope is a world that
they won't grow up into.
And intentionally,
my husband and I
have gone out and sought
almost specialist storybooks
that feature strong
women characters in them
to make sure that--
and "Rosie Revere,
Engineer," if anyone's
interested in that
range of books.
They're very exciting, but
they're not readily available.
They're on special order
and all sorts of things.
I guess for me, part of
making women's equality more
of a reality is in how
I raise my children
and finding those opportunities
to grow little boy feminists.
And it's not as easy
as I thought it would
be to find those opportunities.
So I think making it clear
and making a clear choice
path for parents, I think, is an
important part of that mission
as well.
CATHERINE MAYER: I think one
of the most interesting things,
when I was looking at the
science of sex and gender,
is the research that
shows how very early
the gendered messaging
is going through--
the sort of pink and
blue binary that you get.
So a lot of my
friends said to me,
oh, I didn't think that boys
and girls were necessarily
that different and that it
was all culturally imposed
until I had my children.
And then the moment
I had my children,
I realized, oh,
no, it's absolutely
from the moment they're born.
And actually, all the research
shows you that from the moment
they're born, they are
getting those messages.
So even people pick
up girl babies more
than they pick up boy babies.
And they treat them differently.
And they've done all sorts of
very interesting experiments
in dressing babies but in
a culture that makes people
think they're a different sex.
And they've done
experiments with monkeys
as well to try and find out
what it would look like.
And then they realize that
monkey communities actually
pass on gendered roles,
too, in interesting ways.
So it's very, very hard
to avoid that messaging,
even for people who
are trying to bring up
their kids as feminists.
But making that effort already
makes such a difference.
And it is amazing
when you go back
to books and films that
were childhood favorites
and you haven't looked at
them since you were a child,
and then you look at them
and they're terrifying,
they're kind of propaganda.
And it's amazing.
JON SKEET: And TV shows and
films and all of culture.
CATHERINE MAYER: Yeah.
Which is, by the way,
something I deal with in my--
let me pronounce
it in the BBC way--
Equalia.
One of my questions in
terms of, do we actually
have to censor and get rid of
this huge cultural heritage
in order to create and
maintain a gender-equal world?
And I think any
society that starts
destroying its cultural
heritage is, in fact,
veering into fascism.
So the answer is, no.
But you can see all
sorts of countries
where they have found ways to
contextualize what they have
and to treat it differently.
So it's a very real issue.
And it's a very real impediment.
And you just pick up
any newspaper any day
and you look for the
women in that newspaper.
And you will very often
find an attractive woman
on the front cover.
I happened to see "The
Times" on the way here today.
And there was a
very nice picture
of Angelina Jolie on the cover.
Now she's doing
something very important.
But that's not why her
picture is on the cover,
because it's a picture
of her on the cover.
It is not a big story
about what she's doing
or a headline about
what she's doing,
which is the way a "men's
issue" would be treated
would be with the
headline and the story
and not much of a picture.
The other women that
you will find in papers
are very often
victims rather than
having agency of their own.
So this everywhere
you look, it's
really, really hard
to find something
where that isn't happening.
And for parenting, I think
it is one of the absolutely
key issues, but dealable with.
We can do this.
JON SKEET: And just
to reassure you
that your experience of
finding children's books
is certainly not only
yours, there was a video--
I think Sophie may have
Tweeted it-- recently
of a mother and
daughter at a bookstore.
And they took the
children's section
and first removed
all the books that
didn't have any women in them.
And that was most of them.
And then removed the
ones where women only
had tiny or didn't
say anything, and then
the ones that only served to
be princesses or whatever.
And it's just terrifying,
all of these things.
I think we're probably at
a stage of opening it up
for any other questions.
So I will run the mic around.
That's fine.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I have a question.
Imagine you're
the CEO of Google.
How would you foster gender
equality in the world
if you had all the resources?
CATHERINE MAYER: If I
was the CEO of Google,
how would I foster it in
the world or the company?
AUDIENCE: Gender
equality-- in the world.
CATHERINE MAYER: In the world.
I would probably do even
more than Google is already
doing to foster
it in the company,
because starting at home is
always a really good place.
Google is a really
interesting company
and looking for huge,
transformative technologies.
And I know that I
actually talk in the book
to Sarah Hunter at Google X
about the potential impact
of the self-driving car.
And there is a gendered
impact of that.
It's quite difficult to
tease out, at this point.
But it could be
something that helps
women in all sorts of ways.
It might have ways of
enhancing female security.
It might help with women
because of that unequal share
of caring duties, et cetera.
But on the other
hand, you might say
that it would be better to share
out the caring duties more,
rather than solving it.
So that's, by the way,
always a danger of technology
is that technology will
come at solving things.
Rather than solving
the root problem,
it will say, OK, let's maintain
this structural imbalance
but find a way to fix
it in a different way.
But I would like Google X--
in fact, they can take me on.
Sorry, this is not
a job application--
but to devote the
same amount of energy
that it is devoting to
solving problems of--
well, there are so many things.
Self-driving cars are-- but all
sorts of other energy issues
and the other things that
Silicon Valley is looking
at the moment, like
universal basic income,
and all these great moonshot
technologies and thought
processes.
But I see very little
that's actually designed
to create gender equality.
So where is the
moonshot technology?
Or where is the
great, big thinking
and the great, big investment
in gender equality,
because gender
equality is something
that will benefit everyone?
So it isn't just a
matter of social justice.
It's a matter of logic
and self-interest.
And the reason I'm saying
that is because I don't really
expect business--
I expect businesses
to be ethical.
But I don't expect them
to necessarily respond
to social justice concerns.
But this is good business.
This is good economics.
It should be happening.
So yes, Google X, do your thing.
JON SKEET: Other questions?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Thanks.
So I just wanted to ask a
bit around how much outreach
you're doing to, I guess,
leverage the female members
of other political parties.
To put this into
context, my mother
is women's officer for her
local labor constituency.
And she has had such
difficulty prising away
the list of female members
from all the other officers who
are all men.
She's really struggling
to leverage that.
And when I spoke to her about
the Women's Equality party,
she wasn't aware that she
could be both a Labor party
member and a member
of your party as well.
How much do you look to work
together actively and leverage
the fact that politics
doesn't have to be
a monogamous relationship?
CATHERINE MAYER: Exactly.
No, that's a hugely
important point.
The answer is, we've
been working right
from the very beginning,
talking very intensively
to other parties, looking
at really inventive ways
of working with them.
Hadda's actually been
involved directly
in drafting legislation on--
she worked with the Lib
Dems on drafting legislation
to combat revenge pornography.
And that's going through now?
Where's--
HALLA GUNNARSDOTTIR:
No, it's [INAUDIBLE].
CATHERINE MAYER: It's dead.
OK.
That's the problem
with all these things.
It was going through
the last time I looked.
And on Brexit, we
had an amendment,
which was put forward for us by
Caroline Lucas of the Greens,
that we drafted and that got the
most cross-party support of any
of the amendments.
So that's a more
straightforward way
of working with the parties.
But we're also
looking at other ways
of collaborating, exploring
all of these possibilities.
On the membership question,
we opened our party
to members of other parties.
Some of the other
parties then reacted
by trying to push out some of
the people who had joined us,
because they want to
enforce monogamy at a time
when clearly we should
all be polyamorous.
But we have had really good
collaboration from most
of the parties anyway.
So at our first
party conference,
I shared the stage
with Sal Brinton, who's
the president of Lib
Dems, with Nicky Morgan
from the Conservatives, and with
Amelia Womack from the Greens.
The Labor party
didn't send anyone.
And I think that one of
the things with Labor
is they tend to think they are
the party of gender equality.
So we have more of
a job of work to do.
All of the women in Labor
know that's not true.
But they're quite conflicted
about how to respond to that.
I think there are such
great women in that party.
And it has done great things
for women in the past.
So none of this is
to speak against any
of the achievements of Labor.
But somebody Tweeted during
the Labor party leadership
recently that if Labor
ran a race for leader that
was all women, a man would win.
And sometimes you feel
that that is true.
JON SKEET: We have time
for one last question.
I won't speak to
the irony of letting
a man have the last word.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
That was great.
One of the conflicts or
constrictions I have is,
you said that equality
isn't about minimizing
the differences, which
I completely agree with.
But then--
CATHERINE MAYER: That
it's not about it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it's not about
minimizing the differences.
And then on the
other hand, if we
say it's about celebrating
those differences,
we fall into this trap
of stereotyping genders.
And I think we often say
that, oh, the differences are
that women are
always collaborative
and men are always
forthright or whatever,
which we know is not true.
So I find it very difficult
to balance in my head,
how do we go about equality
not being about making us
all the same, and then
on the other side of us,
not saying that a woman has
to be like this or a man
has to be like that?
How do you balance
that in your head?
And how do we communicate that?
CATHERINE MAYER: It's
a very good question.
And I think one of the
reasons that women are often
quite defensive and in terms
of describing ourselves
as nicer and more collaborative
than your lot is because you've
allowed us so little--
I don't mean you
personally-- but we
have been allowed so little
ownership of most of our lives
or defining ourselves
that the bits
that we can define
for ourselves,
we get a bit too defensive
about sometimes--
so the myth of us being a
lot nicer than you, which
was exploded for me on about
the third ad hoc steering
committee that we had
where we started arguing
and came up with a
much better solution.
And I think having said that,
one happy coincidence is
that I deal with a lot
of this in the book.
So when you read the
book, you'll know.
But I think it is a
really important question.
What we have to do is find
ways of knowing who we are
and what we could
be if we did not
have these stereotypes
imposed on us.
So it is not our business
to enforce stereotypes,
but to encourage and
celebrate diversity.
We are also an
intersectional party.
So we are a party that
understands that being female
is a huge structural
disadvantage that
intersects with other
kinds of disadvantage
and discrimination.
So if you are a woman
of color, you're
going to be at a far greater
disadvantage, for example,
than me, who grew up without
that particular thing.
But now that I'm getting
older, I'm encountering ageism.
So there are all
these ways that we
need to analyze what's
going on and understand it.
But to analyze and understand
differences is also to be
on the way towards also
appreciating and celebrating
and enabling, rather than-- this
is not about creating some kind
of one-size-fits-all solution.
And it is definitely not about
replicating the current order
but just with a few women
sitting in glass offices
at the top of towers.
But the Equalia that I
describe in the book--
the gender-equal world--
it is not a perfect world.
It isn't a utopia.
But the point about it
is that it's achievable,
and it's a lot
better than this one.
JON SKEET: That sounds like
a very positive message
on which to finish.
So thank you so much.
We could keep talking for hours
and hours and hours, I'm sure.
And hopefully, we will
have you back again.
And we can continue
the conversation
and continue it on social
media and everything else.
But for tonight, thank
you so much, Catherine.
CATHERINE MAYER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, really.